قبل ان اتي تحدثت الى رئيس
اوكرانيازلنزكي وتحدثنا عما تقوم به
المانيا وستقوم به في المستقبل سيداتي
سادتي
العام الماضي
يتضح لنا
اننا
الاستمرار بعدم حصولنا على الغاز من روسيا
الازمه الاقتصاديه واننا في الشتاء لن
نتمكن من البقاء في التعامل مع هذه
الاسباب قطر قالوا انا الشتاء سيكون قاسي
جدا وان الربيع سيكون اشكاليه وكثير من
القضايا الاخرى التي كان بالامكان ان
وجهها المانيا
تصفيات اختي
والان نغير
بنانا تحتيه باسرع ما يمكن وقد صعدنا
النمو الاقتصادي والغاز والنفس
تمكننا من ايجاد بدائل وتمكننا من
تحمل تبعات همم
هذه الازمه وغطينا
انا باسمع
ولكن الحكومه
وضعت حدا لهذه الازمه الاقتصاديه واعتقد
ان التقرير
سيثبت ذلك والان يمكننا ان نقول بكل
تاكيد باننا اثبتنا انفسنا واننا
تمكنا من انجاز كل شيء في الوقت المناسب
وتخذنا الخطوات اللازمه وكل المحطات محطات
الطاقه
النوويه حصلت على الغاز
المسال والشاهد في المانيا
هذه الخطوات الايجابيه لصالحه المانيا
كل جهودنا باسرع ما يمكن فان اردنا ان
ننجح لابد ان نتحرك سريعا وقد اثبتنا اننا
قادرين على ذلك وبالتالي علينا ان نستمر
اعني هنا ببناء ال- التربينات الهوائيه في
البحر
الاقتصاد في العالم همم استغل عن
المنتجات المنتجات الكربونيه
بعلم محمد
[تصفيق]
والاحترام لكلي ابطالنا الذين قدموا
الكثير
سيداتي وسادتي
لها اقتصادنا هي بسبب حرب الامبرياليه
والاعتداء على اوكرانيا وعلى مدى عقود في
اوروبا كنا نعتقد اننا لدينا مبادئ واضحه
اما الان بوتن فقد وضع السكون
والتساؤل حول هذه المساله وكيف يمكن ان
يتغير الواقع بالقوه وهذا ما يحدث الان
وما تقوم به روسيا هذه التغيرات العالميه
التي ذكرتها في هذه القاعه سابقا
ولهذا السبب اعتقد انه من الافضل ان
نتعاون مع الشركائنا الخارجين ونقدم
لاوكرانيا التمويل والمساعدات الانسانيه
وتقديم السلاح
واعلنا من من موقف المانيا المانيا
من الدول الاولى في تزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح وكثير من القرارات التي
تضع المانيا في مقدمه الدول الداعمه
لاوكرانيا وسنكون الدوله التي
همم اكبر همم
عاليه جدا لهذا السبب تاخذنا قرارا بتقديم
سلاح الثقيل
ونتحدث عن
الدبابات والدفاعات الجويه والارزتين
والصواريخ ايضا
وانظمه الباتريوت التي ستقدم لاوكرانيا
والقرار حول ذلك اتخذ مؤخرا لتما تتمكن
اوكرانيا من دفاعا عن نفسها كل هذه
القرارات اتخذت بتنسيق وتعاون مع حلفائنا
ولهذا السبب فان هذه الاجراءات كفؤه
تجدي نفعا والنجاحتا
سنواصل التصرف بهذا الشكل ومع الولايات
المتحده اتخذنا قرارا بان نقدم دبابات
البرادلي والمانيا
قدم قدم
المزيد من المؤن هذا تعاون مهم وهو المبدا
الاساسي الصحيح والاسلم لان هذه الحرب على
الاراضي الاوربيه
ليست على جدار برلين بل هي على دوله
وهي اوكرانيا ويجب ان نبذل كل الجهود لدعم
اوكرانيا وفي الوقت ذاته
نريد ان نتجنب تصعيد هذا الصراط
نحوله دون وقوع حرب بين روسيا
سلوك
وعلي ان اقول
ان نتحدث عن الدقه
ولكن مهما كنا دقيقين من صعب ان نحكم ما
هي القرارات الاسلم اتخذنا قرارا بان نمضي
قدما وان نحافظ على المبادئ وهذا المبدا
الوحيد الذي يمكن ان نعتمد عليه في مثل
هذا الوضع الخطير وتعزيز امني المانيا
واوروبا كامله
في انشاعده نبتدي بوندس بيجيئهم
باذن الله
على القرار الذي اتخذته الحكومه مؤخرا
وانه يزود اييه لاب تو دبابات لابر 2
قررنا نقدمها لاوكرانيا وهذا القرار
تمخضع عن حوار المكثف ما شركائه وحلفائنا
للتاكيد على ان
هذا الامر مهم جدا
على الاخرين بقى لنا نستمر في التعاون ضمن
الاوضاع هنا ونواصل في هذا التعاون حتى
المستقبل
السيد
سالتزم نعم سالتزم بالوقت نوال نقدم
الدبابات اللازمه
وسنقدم
ليبرتو ليفربول
كذلك سنضرب المهندسين على كيفيه صيانه
واصلاح هذه الدبابات سيدات وسادتي هذا
مبدا مهم جدا
وهو
نظام كفو وسلاح اكثر والامر السليم
اننا لا نقدمه بمفردنا بل بتنسيق وتعاون
مع الاخرين وانا اعلم ان مواطنين قلقين من
هذا القرار
وحجم هذا القرار
واهميه هذه السلاح لكنني ودنا نقول لجميع
المواطنين ارجو ان تثقوا به وان تثق
بالحكومه الالمانيه
نحن ننسق على مستوى دولي لذلك نعلم انه من
الممكن ان نقدم هذه المساعده دون اي
مخاطره لبلادنا والا تتطور الامور
والاتجاه الخاطئ ولذلك سنه استمر
بالتزامنا بهذه القواعد
[تصفيق]